good
[Music]
hello how are you greeted by sal and jaramillo
with your brief information the
governor alone said that nevada is not ready
to proceed to phase 3 we have been
in phase 2 for several weeks now but
due to the increase in cases per youth
iteam the governor said that we are not
ready he alone said that
an increase in the more places there will be
at the doors is to be expected and due to the increase
in detention tests he assured that his
team needs more time to evaluate
the virus and its impact in the last
weeks at the moment there is no
scheduled date for phase number 3
clark county wants to know your opinion
regarding a plan they have that is how to
transform clark county it is an
online survey that details
priorities and changes for the future
we have the link  so you can
participate in the news now dotcom and there are
more detention testing sites for
the coronavirus around the valley
wal mart will open its three
additional sites at  your ap
lake mead and american pass locations effective these
are available today and on
thursday mornings you must be over 18
to be able to take the test and now
we move on to the weather forecast it
will be a sunny day with some breezes
for the last tuesday  spring
we will be in the high 90s for today and a
little cooler tomorrow have a
nice day i am sali jaramillo and this
was in disney en español
[Music]